[Music]
starting this hour off sacramento
california scott's with us hey scott how
are you
good how are you better than i deserve
man what's up
all right so i'm a teacher and the way
the pay works is that
the more post bachelor degree units that
you have the higher your pay is so when
you reach
a certain threshold you'll move over
on the pay scale to the right and the
further over to the right the more money
you make so i'm trying to figure out if
it makes sense to pursue
a master's degree to get more post
bachelor degree units or
if i should do professional development
seminars
which can give you units but
i'm not sure if it's worth doing 97
professional development seminars and
paying for those units that route
well
you can look at it several different
ways one way you would look at it and it
sounds like the way you're asking the
question is simply this
what does it cost
to increase
the boxes that you can check to the
right
and then how much money do you get
increased income due to that cost so
it's the cost versus the benefit
analysis right
so you spend a thousand dollars on
either of these whether it's pursuing
the master's or the professional
development and uh your income goes up x
right so is it worth it yeah it needs to
go up you know and you get it every year
with the income you only spend a
thousand dollars once
uh on in either case so that's good the
other thing that you can add to that is
a collection of personal development
seminars
really just gives you that collection
you do get all the knowledge from them
if however you did a collection that led
to a master's degree you do come out of
that with a master's degree which is a
nice
extra benefit to have that so i'm
probably going that route if the costs
are similar
okay yeah and from what i can gather the
cost for the masters
is anywhere from three to five x of what
it takes to do
the professional development and the
professional development it might be a
three-day seminar so the commitment is
far less yeah but what's the return
right so and it seems to me that it
costs maybe a hundred to two hundred
dollars per unit
uh if you will on the professional
development where it costs around
someone that can gather about five
hundred dollars per unit if you're doing
a master's program okay and then how
much do they pay you increase your pay
for a unit
so
it's in increments of 15 units so if i
did the masters it would bump me over
two whole columns and that would be
about a 5 000 per year
pay increase
okay and the master's degree would cost
what
about 15 000
okay so in three years you break even
and the personal development would cost
you
uh it sounds like about five thousand
right for the same amount of
column movement
did i do that right
yes that's correct okay so one's three
times more than the other both of them
increase you about so you can spend five
thousand can you do both
it doesn't do any good because there's
only so many columns
yeah they
right there there's
five columns i think yeah if you do both
it doesn't yeah if you did both it
doesn't keep moving you along it so you
wouldn't get a return
right you could you could you max out at
a certain number of units and then it's
just yeah
you can't go any further over
okay
well just purely on the dollars you
would do the professional development
right
5 000 gets you 15 000 or uh uh i mean 5
000 gets you 5 000 a year or fifteen
thousand gets you five thousand a year
right did i do that right yes
uh-huh yeah now this but so you know
you're paying 10 grand for the privilege
of having a masters
that get that that does not increase
your income
if i'm understanding your scenario right
that's now there's a of course the value
then is do you want to have a master's
and you know do you want to spend an
extra ten thousand dollars in order to
have that because that might have uses
other times in your life
to have that under your belt versus 67
professional development
uh one other question uh that's a little
bit uh
when you finish the same number of units
of professional development versus the
masters
uh have you increased your knowledge
base
more with the masters that gives you
more job satisfaction you're better at
your job when you go to the masters or
is it about the same or are the
professional development actually better
because they're more practical
i'm going to if i had to guess i'm going
to say that the professional development
would be a better increase in knowledge
because there are so many different
options whereas the masters you're more
singularly focused
okay
is there any other reason you should do
a master's then because you got better
knowledge and less money spent on the
professional development side i'm just
walking through this with you i don't
know what i'm talking about i'm just
helping you with the critical thinking
path okay
and so the only thing i hear you're
getting for that extra 10 grand is
substandard knowledge
and a master's degree
right yeah it i don't think it gives me
anything other than
the master's degree title unless i
wanted to
pivot later in my career but i don't see
myself wanting to stop teaching i don't
want to i don't want to move into
administration that sounds well if you
did choose that you can always go back
and work on the masters later but in the
meantime i'm going to jump on 5k for 5k
and let's get this professional
development stuff under your belt get
the increased knowledge the increased
joy of teaching because you're better at
it and
and you can always go back and do the
masters later and you may have a
different direction with your masters if
you're doing that because you might be
aiming at administration if you chose to
make that that shift in your track
that's just me thinking through it with
you dude i i'm not an expert on
education uh in terms of the your field
or anything like that i'm just looking
at the return on investment and what's
the quality of what i'm buying and i'm
just thinking through it
and what that does is it puts all the
mystery of ooh a master's degree
and it basically tells you doesn't mean
crap
that's what it tells you
um after we get after we cut through all
of it that's what it came down to so
good question that's interesting thanks
for letting me walk through that with
you